love you guys
ben from boise i had a question for you
guys just how to
tip the knee if you will in the shower
as we all do uh would you rather know
when you're gonna die
to the exact day and time yeah not know
at all and live your life on history
shout out to everybody anthony studio
love you guys love your content gang
gang
fun
thank you for clarifying just making
sure everybody knows appreciate it
[Laughter]
doesn't he yeah he does uh i'm gonna
have to fire
chin oh dude yeah easy or as he calls
himself now
jin yeah dude whatever his name is but
we could easily fire him
but i'll say this dude what do
first of all they call it uh susio what
do they call it it's taking a shower
is dirty dirty okay i play like a dirty
boy
a dirt nap you're trying to say i don't
know nubia what do they call it
nubia
where's my wife yeah yo no say posible
muerte
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and what i'm trying to say right now is
what do what would you what do you think
about that when that man says what he
said
would you want to uh know the day you're
going to die i don't i'm not afraid of
death i don't want to know
let it come whenever it comes oh no i'd
like to know you would
yeah i get my get my finances in order
maybe maybe
check a couple bucket list things you
know you wouldn't want to know
i don't uh
damn it would be crazy if you knew
because suddenly you would really get
into
gear i feel like you'd appreciate life a
lot more if you knew
they're like hey bren 47 but go damn
better get going dude i could see you
dying at 47. me too
and i hate to say that but no no i'm
with you man name a big grandpa
that's not a big there are guys john
candy my dad's not i mean my dad's
pretty young
john candy's dead 16 years
and he was an uncle uh but i'll say that
not a lot of uh
big grandpas with cauliflowers yeah dude
a lot of uh do mexican people get scared
about death or do they have a lot of
uh what is it called you have the day of
the dead so you guys think
right i think we live by no fear and it
comes from all the way back to
our native roots and it when we were
actually battling the conquerors you
know just
live by no fear go out there and fight
as hard as you can and
don't be afraid of anything [ __ ] yeah
that's so gangster i knew it bro that's
gangster
you never seen coco huh coco is great
i've tried to watch it it's a good one
um and there's so much catholicism so
it's like
belief in an afterlife most people think
is gonna happen
as long as yeah now a lot of guys um
what do you think cat do you think that
it's okay you want to die or know when
you're gonna die or what is it no i
don't want to know
i feel like i not much would change in
my life either way and i will
just start like living like for the day
like if they told you
30 you're 20 you what four yeah no
six years you want to start i don't know
i'm a little weird in that i feel like
i've done
everything i could have possibly wanted
to do when i was like 23.
damn oh well like everything now is just
like a bonus
oh this is uh like a bonus where it's
like oh it's cool that i do this but if
i don't i'm not tripping
okay wow this got dark how's that i've
achieved everything
that i wanted to oh yeah yeah well i
wouldn't say that out loud because then
life might think oh well
curveball you achieved here you go yeah
yeah
here you go with this achieve this
casket boo-boo
yeah achieve this six feet hundred huh
yeah you just don't know
nick what about you you wanna know when
you're gonna die i don't i am afraid of
death
a lot
you look like you search for bigfoot on
youtube
yeah you definitely had a couple of big
cups of sprite
i do
[Laughter]
yeah i'd rather not know i hope it's
long time in the future yeah
got a lot a lot of stuff to accomplish
yeah
i'm wearing a tank top every episode
we're starting the streak right now
yeah sending the tanks
yeah tank of the week yeah we'll put the
uh we'll put that
we'll put march last size large yeah
we'll put the mail-in address on the uh
on the youtube videos
the thinner the arms the
[Music]
it's the king and better stand